ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูนี้สวัสดีครับครูหญิง
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนเออไม่คนนี้พูดบ่อยแล้ว
เลยอยากให้อ้อมาได้สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุก
คนที่ไม่ได้ลืมใช่ไหมหรือลืม
เป็นเทคนิคหรือเปล่าลืม
ทำเป็นทำเป็นเนียนฮัลโหลแต่เนียน
โอเคแต่ก่อนที่จะลืมเขียนวันที่นะคะก็ขอ
เพลงเขียนวันที่ก่อนๆๆครับคืนนี้วันนี้
วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันพุธครับวันนี้วันพุธ
ใช่วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
22 ครับค่ะเดือนอะไรคะเดือนมิถุนายนครับ
แค่นี้ถุนายนอุ้ยดีพ.ต.ต.อะไรคะอีพศ.
2565 ครับค่ะปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2  022 ครับ
ค่ะแล้วตอนนี้ที่คุณนิคอยู่เวลากี่โมง
แล้วคะตอนนี้ครับที่เมืองคูนิสอยู่
แป๊บนึงนะอยู่ดูจะเอา
แบบที่สี่
แล้ววง
จะยังเช้าอยู่ไงยังเช้าอยู่มันก็ต้องแบบ
เอ้เต็มที่เท่า
ใช่แล้วผู้หญิงครับเมืองที่ผู้หญิงอยู่
กี่โมงแล้วเมืองที่กูหญิงอยู่เนี่ยก็เร็ว
กว่าครูนิดหนึ่งชั่วโมงเนาะก็ 10 โมงแล้ว
ค่ะ
10:01
9 โมงดีแล้วครูนิคกินข้าวหรือกินอะไร
หรือยังคะกินข้าวแล้วช้างพักกินข้าวแล้ว
คุณทำเองไหมปกติทำเองแต่วันนี้ขี้เกียจก็
เลย and ทำ
งั้นงั้นครูนี้ก็ไม่ควรชอบทำอาหารสิคะชอบ
ครับชอบแล้วอ้า
ชอบทำอาหารเวลาอยู่ต่างประเทศนะแล้วค่อย
อยู่ประเทศไทยล่ะอยู่ประเทศไทยซื้อเอา
เพราะถูกกว่าหญิงค่ะเพราะคุณนี้จัดอยู่
อะไรอยู่ที่ไทยอยู่บ้านคนเดียวเราไปซื้อ
ของข้างนอกกะหยังอาหารตามสั่งกล่องละ 30
40 บาทมันถูกกว่าเยอะเพราะทำเองในจะซื้อ
เนื้อซื้อน้ำปลาซื้อน้ำมันขี้เกียจล้าง
ด้วยไม่คุกหายๆหยุดอยู่กรุงเทพดีหรือว่า
อยู่ที่ไทยอ่ะนะอยู่ที่ไหนก็ได้นะคะอยู่
คนเดียวซื้อกินซื้อกินน่ะซื้อกินเองนะคะ
กินข้าวหรอ
คะอาหารกินอ่ะผู้ที่ให้เต็มๆแล้วกันอาหาร
กินเนี่ยถูกปลาสกุลนี้อยู่ต่างประเทศ
เนี่ยการซื้ออาหารกินเองเนี่ยมันอาจจะแพง
กว่าหรือก็ไม่ง่ายเหมือนที่ไทยไหม
ใช่ๆเพราะว่าอย่างเราอ่ะไปซื้อไปซื้อข้าว
กินอย่างที่อเมริกานะอย่างต่ำเลยเนี่ยก็
ต้องสิทธิ์ดอนละอ่ะตอน 1  US  $10 เนี่ย
ยังไม่รวมทิปณ
ทิพย์เข้าอีกแล้วเราก็โอเคทั้งหมดก็
ประมาณอ่าน 10 ดอนอาหารน้ำทิพย์รวมกันก็
15 ดอนถ้าเราก็จะผ้าร้อยอ่ะนะถ้าตอนนี้
น้องหนึ่ง 1 เหรียญก็ 30 กว่าๆแล้วๆใช่
เจาะ 10  15 ดอลลาร์เนี่ย
สามารถไปซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตเราซื้อของทำได้
ทั้งวันเลยไม่ได้กินได้แค่มื้อเดียวเห้ย
ใช่คนนี้ก็เลยโอเคทำกับข้าวแต่ก็กลับทำ
คุณนี้หน้าชอบทำอาหารแต่แค่อยู่ที่ไทยไม่
ได้ทำเยอะเหมือนอยู่ที่ประเทศแล้วปกติคุณ
นิคทำอาหารไทยไหมคะถ้าแบบอยู่ต่างประเทศ
คำครับทำอาหารไทยจะชอบทำอาหารไทยมากกว่า
อาหารฝรั่ง
นายจริงๆอาหารฝรั่งก็ทำแต่จะไม่ชอบทำพวก
พาสต้าเพราะว่าภาคใต้เนี่ยเวลาทำพวกครีม
พวกซอสเนี่ยคุณนิคจะทำแล้วผสมผิดแล้วมัน
ไม่เหมือนกับที่เราอยากกินอ่ะค่ะหน้าแต่
ถ้าอาหารอุ่นอาหารฝรั่งก็ให้คนฝรั่งทำใช่
ไหมเราเป็นคนไทยก็ทำอาหารไทยๆเราก็จะง่าย
ๆว่าเหมือนจะใส่น้ำปลาใส่ซีอิ๊วแบบเนี้ย
น้ำตาลลองเติมได้จ้าหารฝรั่งบางทีอย่าง
ที่พาต้าลดใส่ครีมไปเราทีมมันจืดมันก็
เติมได้แค่เกลือกับพริกไทยก็ใส่น้ำปัญหา
ไม่ได้นะมันก็จะแบบ
ดรีมกับน้องหมาฮารวมกันเออคุณนี้เคยนะแบบ
เหมือนกับทำทำพาสต้านะหลายกินแล้วเหมือน
จะเพราะใส่ครีมไปเอ๊ะมันเริ่มจืดแล้วก็
เติมเกลือ S ทีนี้มันเริ่มเข็มละทดสลับไป
มามันใส่มันเยอะเกินไปอ่ะแล้วก็จะทิ้งละ
อันนี้มันไม่ใช่แบบครีมของพลาซ่าแล้วมัน
คือซุปไปคือซุปแล้วซะ
ใช่แต่ก็ชอบก็ทำอาหารผู้หญิงชอบไหมทำไม่
เลยนะคะผู้หญิงไม่ชอบทำอาหารคือถ้าอยู่
เองเมื่อจอนอยู่กรุงเทพก็อยู่คนเดียว
เหมือนกันก็สั่งบ้างทำบ้างแต่ก็จะทำเป็น
อะไรที่ทำง่ายๆอ้ะกูนิแบบเข้าต้มมข้าวผัด
ไข่ต้มเปื่อยต้องก็จะไปการทำอาหารไหมน่า
จะไม่หรอบอกว่าจริงๆก็เป็นนะก็แค่เข้า
ครัวเปิดเตาแก๊สเนี่ยก็ทำอาหารแล้วเธอใช่
ค่ะแต่ว่าปกติเป็นคนไม่ได้ทำอาหารเก่ง
แล้วก็ไม่ใช่คนทำอาหารอร่อยโอ้ยแบกหาม
เข้าผ่านก็ได้แล้วนะได้ก็คือข้าวผัดผู้
หญิงก็ชอบคือทำแบบที่เราชอบใช่ไหมคะแต่
ว่าปกติครูนิคทำอาหารเนี่ยก็จะมีเมนูใช่
ไหมที่แบบเราแบบเรารู้สึกว่าเราทำเก่งอ่ะ
นี่ไหมแบบเบนูนเขาเรียกอะไรอ่ะเมนูเก่ง
ของอีกหรอนี้มีของคู่นิดเนี่ยเมนูเก่ง
เนี่ยจะไปในนี่
แกงซื้อแกงจืดไม่อ้อต้มมะระกระดูกหมูเออ
ช็อคกินมากเลยนะคุณเดี๋ยวเปิดรูปใน
โทรศัพท์ให้ดูนะคะไม่ได้เปิดไมค์เขาไม่ดู
น่ะ
นั่นแหละจะเป็นเมนูเก่งคือคือค่ะอันนั้น
อ่ะจะเป็นอยากทรายทองนี้ก็เป็นของคุณนี้
ก็เป็นกระดูกหมู
วันนี้แค่ออกแบบนี้แบบนี้แบบนี้
ชายๆเลยคือกระดูกหมูใช่ไหมก็สมจืดหนอต้อง
ตื่นมาละนายก็น่ารักคุณนี่ก็จะตอนแรก
เนี่ยไม่รู้ว่า
คำเก่งนะนี้เพราะว่าก็ทำกินคนเดียวมันก็
ไม่ได้อะไรแต่ก็มีช่วงโควิชนะเนาะเพื่อน
ก็แบบไม่เอาไปที่ร้านอาหารร้านนี้ก็เลย
อ่าโอเคเดี๋ยวทำกับข้าวให้กินลองไหมเพื่อ
ทำได้หรออบเพื่อนเนี่ยมันก็จะมีบางคนที่
ไม่รู้ว่าคุณทำอาหารเป็น
เขาไม่เคยเห็นคุณนี้ทำอาหารที่ไทยและที่
แล้วก็ทำไปให้กินแล้วเพื่อนก็บอกว่าเฮ้ย
อร่อยนะเนี่ยไม่ลืมทำได้แล้วก็แบบ S อัน
นี้คือเราหรือเปล่าเนี่ย
เออได้แล้วหลังจากนั้นนะเพื่อนก็ให้ทำมัน
เนี่ยราะตลอดว่าเออทำต้มมันเนี่ยต้มมะระ
ต้มมะระก็เลยโอเคใช่อือได้ๆใช้เวลานะ
เพราะว่ากระดูกหมูนะจะให้มันนิ่มมันต้อง
ต้มทิ้งไว้ล่ะ
เขาถ้ากระดูกหมูมาให้ตรงไหนตรงนี้นะคะที่
ที่แบบ
กระดูกหมูว่าเนี่ยนะถ้ามันไม่นิ่มมันไม่
อร่อยใช่น่าจะใช่แล้วก็มีอีกอย่างนึงที่
คุณนัยจะยังไม่เคยทำแต่ชอบค่ะไงคะตัวนี้
ก็ชอบกินผัดซีอิ้ว
ใส่อันไม่เคยทำยังไม่เคยทำยังไม่เคยทำชอบ
ผัดซีอิ๊วปลาหมึกคุณพี่ก็ชอบกินอาหารทะเล
เพราะว่าผัดซีอิ๊วหน่อยนะคะอ่ะผัดซีอิ๊ว
เนี่ยก็เป็นผู้หญิงก็คิดว่าเป็นอาหารไทย
ที่นักเรียนหลายๆคนรู้จักอ่ะแล้วก็เป็น
อีกหนึ่งเมนูไหมที่คนต่างชาติเนี่ยมา
ประเทศไทยก็จะ
หากินน่ะใช่เพราะว่ามันไม่เผ็ดด้วยตายค่ะ
แต่ว่าพาซีอิ๊วเนี่ยผัดซีอิ้วอะไรก็ได้
หนีไก่ปลาหมึกผู้
ๆอันนี้มันคือเป็นเหมือนเขาเรียกอะไรเป็น
อาหารไทยคะว่าเป็นความพิเศษของอาหารไทย
แล้วกันว่าเมนูหนึ่งอย่างแต่เนื้อสัตว์
ที่คุณอยากใส่อะคือใส่อะไรก็ได้ที่เราชอบ
ให้
แต่ว่าที่วันเนี้ยก็ดีเลยค่ะคุณนี้เพราะ
ว่าวันเนี้ยผู้หญิงก็จะมาเหมือนไม่ใช่สอน
หรอกเนาะก็จะมาก็สอนนั่นแหละนะคะว่าวิธี
การทําผัดซีอิ๊วผู้หญิงไม่ได้ทำให้ดูนะ
แค่จะบอกว่าต้องเตรียมอะไรบ้างแล้วก็ต้อง
ทำยังไงว่าพูดให้นักเรียนฟังว่ามันต้อง
ออกหรืออะไรแบบนี้โอเคใส่อ่ะค่ะวันนี้
เป็นผัดซีอิ๊วหมูนะแต่เนื้อสัตว์เนี่ยนะ
คะเนื้อสัตว์เนื้อหมูไก่กุ้งปลาหมึกเนี่ย
เปลี่ยนได้นะคะเปลี่ยนได้อ้ะเดี๋ยวเราก็
ต้องมาดูก่อนใช่ไหมคะว่าผัดซีอิ๊วเนี่ยมี
วัตถุดิบอะไรบ้างนะมีเยอะจริงๆอ่ะจริงๆ
มันมีไม่เยอะมันคือผัดซีอิ๊วเนี่ยก็เอา
ที่คุณนิดเพราะคุณไม่เคยทำแต่คุณนี้ดาว
ได้ว่ามันก็จะมีแค่เส้นอย่างนี้ครับเส้น
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวจะเป็นเส้นใหญ่เนาะมันจะหาต้อง
เส้นใหญ่แล้วก็เนื้อสัตว์ใช่ไหมเงินๆแล้ว
ใส่ก็อย่างที่เราบอกกันเมื่อกี้นะว่าจะ
เป็นเนื้ออะไรก็ได้ที่คนอยากจะกินชายใส่
ก็ได้ถ้านักเรียนไม่กินเนื้อสัตว์เป็นตี
แก้มเงิน
ไม่ใส่ก็ได้แล้วก็มีไข่ค่ะไข่นี่คือเกาะ
แล้วก็ขาดไม่ได้เนาะค่ะน้าใช่ค่ะภาษีอยู่
ต้องเป็นผักขนาดนี้คือวัตถุดิบนะคะแล้วก็
ที่เหลือที่อยู่ในถ้วยเล็กๆมีอันนึงคนนี้
ก็ลืม
กระเทียม
ไก่ค่ะเป็นอันหมอเขาน่าจะสับไปกระเทียม
สับกระเทียมสับชายเขาแต่จริงๆอาหารไทยอ่ะ
ใช้กระเทียมเกือบหมดเลยนะฮะถ้าเป็นพวกทำ
เพราะเหมือนกับคนไทยบอกว่าอยากได้กลิ่น
หอมจากกระทะอะไรบ้างแล้วใช่ก็จะต้องใส่
กระเทียมนะคะอันนี้ก็เป็นวัตถุดิบนอนแล้ว
ก็จะมีพวกเครื่องปรุงหรือว่าว่าเราเรียก
และเครื่องปรุงรสนะได้เครื่องปรุงเครื่อง
ปรุงรสพวกซอสแต่ก็ซอส
เครื่องปรุงนั่นแหละอันนี้ก็ตามใจชอบนะคะ
แต่ว่าผัดซีอิ๊วเนี่ย
เราจะใช้น้ำปลาก็ได้อันนี้น่ะคิดว่านี้
น่าจะดูจากในถ้วยนี้น่าจะเป็นซีอิ๊ว
ซีอิ๊วขาว
ครับ
[เพลง]
รอแต่หิวข้าวมันจะหอมกว่าในความคิดคนนึง
นะแต่คนไทยก็จะจะติดน้ำปลามันก็จะแล้วแต่
คนละอ่าอ่ะค่ะน้ำปลามันก็จะอย่างถ้าผู้
หญิงผู้หญิงก็เลือกซีอิ๊วอาหารชนิดเนี่ย
จะเลือกน้ำปลาเพราะว่ายังพาซีอิ๊วเนี่ย
มันจะมีซีอิ้วดำอันนี้อันนี้นะนี่คือ
ซีอิ้วดำคนนี้ก็ไปคิดว่าซีอิ้วดำกับ
ซีอิ๊วปกติรวมกันไม่เอาอยากได้อะไรแปลก
นิดหน่อยไม่รู้ใจแต่ถ้านักเรียนไม่กิน
เนื้อสัตว์ก็ใช้ซีอิ๊วผิวขาวนะคะเพราะว่า
น้ำปลามันเป็นเหลือสัตว์เหรอแต่จ่ายหมด
แล้วนะคะนักเรียนใช่แต่ว่าบางคนก็
เรียกว่าอะไรนะเอ่ออันเนี้ยบางคนก็จะใส่
นี่เลยนะผงชูรสน้องเหงาชัยค่ะอันนี้น่าจะ
ไม่ใช่นะเจ๊วันนี้เป็นน้ำตาลเอ้ย
The บางคนก็จะใส่ผงชูรสเพื่อนคุณนิดเคย
แซวเคยพูดเล่นว่าอ๋ออร่อยชัวร์ไม่ใช่ว่า
อาหารอร่อยชัวร์นะก็บอกว่าคุณนิกะห์ใช้ผง
ชูรสยี่ห้ออร่อยสัว
มันก็เลย
เพราะว่าบางครั้งมันจะเป็นผงชูรสแบบนี้
ฉันไม่รู้ว่าอเมริกามีไหมหรือนักเรียนเคย
เห็นไหมอ่ะมีเออหรือคนไทยบางครั้งก็ใส่
อันนี้ไปเลยค่ะท่านี้เนี่ยคุยก็ไม่รู้ว่า
ผัดซีอิ๊วว่ามันจะใส่ได้ไหมนะก็จะเป็นพวก
รถดีเแบบเนี้ยใส่หน้าอันนี้แทบจะไม่ต้อง
มีน้ำตาไม่ต้องมีซีอิ๊วแล้วเพราะว่าพวกผม
รถดีน่ะมันมีรสชาติแล้วอายใช่
จังหวัดเด็ดสายเป็นวัตถุดิบนะคะอุ้ย
เดี๋ยวเขาเคลียร์ขี้เกียจเขียนไปก่อนเนาะ
เพราะวัตถุดิบนี่คือซีอิ้วดำนะคะซิอิ๊วดำ
มันจะเป็นซอสเหนียวๆให้ผัดซีอิ๊วเนี่ยให้
ผัดซีอิ๊วของเราเนี่ยมันมีสีออกน้ำตาลน้ำ
ตาล
ก็ขั้นตอนแรกนะคะเราก็ต้องหั่นหมูก่อน
เนาะอ่ะมีหูแล้วก็หั่นผักใช่ไหมค่ะก็หัน
กลับจะต้องมีมีดแล้วก็เขียนข่าวต้องมีค่ะ
นะคะนักเรียนมีแต่จะบอกนิดนึงว่าที่
อเมริกาเนี่ยอย่างร้านของร้านของญาติครู
นิดเนี่ยก็เป็นร้านอาหารไทยแต่ภาษีว่าไม่
มีค่ะน้าขอว่าเขาหาไม่ได้แล้วใช้อะไรแทน
น่ะของร้านยาดครูนิดเนี่ยเขาก็จะใช้แครอท
กาพย์บล็อคโคลี่
ใช่รู้สึกว่าหัวถั่วลันเตาที่เป็นถั่วที่
ไม่ได้เป็นเม็ดๆนะเที่ยงเป็นฝากอยู่อ่ะ
อ้า
ใช่ก็ได้นะแต่ว่าบล็อคโคลี่ก็ได้อยู่
เพราะว่าเคอรี่กับคณะมีความคล้ายๆกันๆแต่
คนในเพจชอบค่ะน้าเนาะผัดซีอิ้วนะคะ
ใช่ค่ะต่อไปค่ะแล้วก็เสร็จแล้วเราก็ต้อง
ตั้งเอากระทะใช่ไหมคะทำอาหารเนาะก็ตอนนี้
เป็นกระทะนะคะแล้วก็ตะหลิวสมัยตั้งไฟแล้ว
ก็เจียวกระเทียมใช่มั้ยเหมือนคนนี้บอกคือ
ใส่น้ำมันแล้วก็ใส่กระเทียมสับใช่ๆแล้วก็
เสี่ยวเสี่ยวๆเหมือนกับคนกันไปนิดหน่อย
ให้มันเหมือนกับมีไม่ใช่ว่าไม่แต่สีมัน
เปลี่ยนไปน้ำตาลน้ำตาลๆแล้วก็มีกลิ่น
ประเทียบเนี่ยคือเท่านั้นไม่รู้ว่าจะผัด
จนถึงเมื่อไหร่ก็ปันจะเริ่มมีกลิ่นหอมๆ
ใช่พอเริ่มมีกลิ่นแล้วก็ใส่เนื้อสัตว์ไป
ก่อนมันยังไม่ใส่กาดใส่เนื้อสัตว์เออก็
ถ้าคุณชอบหมูชอบไก่อะไรก็ใส่ลงไปก่อนเลย
นะคะแล้วก็ปรุงรสเลยไหมถ้าเป็นครูนิคใส่
เนื้อสลัดแล้วก็ผัดแล้วก็ปรุงรสไม่ใส่น้ำ
ตาลน้ำปลาหนาวเนี่ยคุณนี้จะ
ตัวเองก่อนเพราะว่าซอสหรือเครื่องปรุงมัน
จะได้เข้ากับเนื้อ
ใช่เพราะว่ามันจะเข้ากันแล้วตอนที่กำลัง
กำลังทำเพราะไม่อย่างนั้นเนี่ยถ้าเนื้อ
มันสุกแล้วเนี่ยใส่ซอสไปมันเครื่องก็จะ
เคลือบข้างนอก
ก็จะเค็มรสจัดอยู่ข้างนอกแต่พอเคี้ยว
เนื้อสัตว์หรือว่าเคี้ยวหมูไปแล้วเนี่ย
ข้างในมันจุดจืดใช่ใช่แต่จริงแต่ว่าเนื้อ
เราหันบางเนี่ยก็ใส่ซอสทีหลังก็ได้
ใส่ค่ะแต่ว่าอย่างเอาผู้หญิงดูมาเดี๋ยว
เขาก็ทำเหมือนครูนิคนะคะก็คือเขาก็ผัด
กระเทียมจนหอมใส่เนื้อสัตว์ใช่ไหมใส่หมู
หรือว่าเนื้อสัตว์อะไรเนี่ยลงไปผัดแล้วก็
ปรุงรสเลยใส่น้ำปลาซีอิ๊วดำซีอิ๊วดำนะคะ
ต้องใส่แต่น้ำปลาหรือว่าซีอิ้วขาวหรือซอส
อะไรเนี่ยนี้แล้วแต่นักเรียนชอบเนาะใส่
น้ำตาล
จัดคุณก็จะไม่ใส่น้ำตาลเพราะว่าคุณนี้คิด
ว่าซีอิ้วดำเนี่ยมันหวาน
จ่ายถ้าบางคนชอบหวานก็ใส่นะคะแล้วก็ผัด
เนาะผัดจนหมูสุกใช่ปะสั่งหมูสุกแล้วก็พอ
เขาใส่เส้นลงไปเนี่ยก็ขาดอีกทีเพราะว่า
มันจะต้องให้เส้นเนี่ยเป็นสีน้ำตาลเนาะ
ค่ะทรายๆแล้วก็ผัดน้องเอาเส้นลงไปผัดจน
เส้นมันเป็นสีน้ำตาลอย่างเงี้ยค่ะนัก
เรียนเออเอ้ย
กินขยายรูปให้ดูนะคะเห็นไหมเส้นเป็นสีน้ำ
ตาล
เขาก็อยากได้วิธีนี้เขาก็จะเอาตะหลิวนะคะ
เอาเส้นเนี่ยมาวางไว้ข้างนึงแล้วก็จงที่
ว่างและก็คือตอบไข่ใส่ลงใบ
ชายมีกูที่ทำแบบนี้ไหมอ่ะถ้าไม่ได้ทำมั้ย
จริงๆอ่ะคุณนี้กะคุณนี้ก็จะทำเหมือนกับ
แอบฝรั่งนิดหน่อยเพราะว่าเต็มที่ชอบตีไข่
แล้วก็เอาลงไปตั้งแต่แรกเลยอ๋ออ๋อก็คือกู
นี่ไม่ได้เอาใส่ลงไปเป็นรูปแบบนี้ใช่ไหม
คะนายคนที่จะจะจริงๆอ่ะเราแล้วแต่อารมณ์
แต่คือจริงจอยทำแบบนี้ได้แต่ว่าบางครั้ง
เนี่ยทอใส่ไข่ตอนท้ายนั้นมันชอบติดกับพระ
อาจาร์ยใส่ชอบแค่นั้นเองคุณเอ่อช่องสวยลง
ไปตอนนี้เลยเหรอคะใส่ก่อนเส้นใส่เอาจริงๆ
คุณ x เนี่ยก็ถามก็คือกระเทียมใช่ไหมแล้ว
ก็ไข่เราก็เนื้อสัตว์ของเล่นขับแล้วก็
ปรุงรสตอนท้ายค่ะถ้าอย่างวิธีนี้เนี่ยก็
คือเขาผัดทุกอย่างเสร็จแล้วแล้วก็เอาเอา
เส้นมาไว้ข้างๆใช่ไหมคะเราก็ให้มีที่ตรง
นี้แล้วก็ตอบไข่ใส่ลงไปแล้วก็ผัดไข่เพราะ
ว่าถ้าตอบไข่ลงไปที่เส้นเนี่ยไข่มันจะเละ
ใช่ๆไม่ชอบ 40 ปะติ๋วไข่มันต้องเป็น
เหมือนไข่ผัดเออๆใช่ๆๆ
แต่ถ้านักเรียนชอบอย่างผู้หญิงผู้หญิงจะ
เป็นคนชอบไข่แบบเร็วอ่ะค่ะคุณก็จะเอาไข่
เนี่ยใส่ลงไปที่เส้นเลยแล้วก็ผัดไข่กับ
เส้นด้วยกันหืออันนี้แล้วแต่ความชอบนะ
แล้วแต่ความชอบแล้วก็คิดว่าคนไทยจะชอบ
เหมือนกันอย่างนี้ล่ะให้มันเหมือนมีไข่
อ่ะมันรวมอยู่ในเส้นเพราะว่าถ้าทำอย่าง
คุณนิคที่แบบฝรั่งทำเนี่ยเขาเอาไข่ใส่
ก่อนอ่ะไข่อ่ะมันจะไม่ได้ติดอยู่กับเส้น
มันเหมือนกับว่าไข่มันจะแยกตัวกันเลยชาย
คะมันก็จะเหมือนหมูเออใช่ใช่ใช่
อันนี้มันเขาก็จะใช้แบบให้ไข่มันมีความ
สุขนิดๆแล้วก็ค่อยเอาเส้นมาผัดรวมกันไข่
มันก็จะติดอยู่ที่เส้น
แล้วก็เสร็จแล้วนักเรียนอย่าลืมใส่ผัด
เอาภาพหายไปไหนอ่ะข้อเท็จใสภาคนะในคิดว่า
อันนี้เนี่ยเขาใส่ไข่ก่อนพอใส่ไข่เสร็จ
แล้วก็เอาผักคะน้าที่เราห้ามเนี่ยลงไปผัด
สุดท้ายแล้วส่วนใหญ่เขาใส่ค่ะสุดท้ายในคู
นิกส์เฮ้ยไม่ๆจริงๆแล้วผักเนี่ยไข่นะคือ
เป็นข้างต่อสุดท้ายเลยเพราะว่าไม่อย่าง
นั้นนะผากกับมันจะไม่สุกใช่คือผู้หญิงก็
คิดว่าถ้าเป็นตัวกูเองผู้หญิงผัดผัดผักก็
คือหมูสุกกันเลยค่ะ
เปอร์เซ็นต์เพราะว่าอย่างที่คุณอีกชอบผัด
ซีอิ๊วเพราะว่าคะน้าคนนี้อยากจะให้มัน
เหมือนจะไม่ไหม้นิดนึง
ก็ใส่ไปแล้วหรือยังแสงเป๊าะแป๊บเนี่ยโอเค
แล้วค่ะอร่อยอร่อยตัวเธอแต่บางคนน่ะผู้
หญิงทุกคนนี้กูหญิงเคยเห็นก็คือเขาอ่ะใส่
เส้นใช่ไหมใส่ไข่เสร็จแล้วพ่อผัดไข่เสร็จ
เนี่ยก่อนที่จะเสร็จอ่ะเขาจะใส่คณะลงไป
สุดท้ายแล้วก็ผักนิดหน่อยให้คณะมันไม่ได้
สู่อ่ะแล้วบอกก็ตลกเออใช่กรอบใส่ใช่ยังไง
เพื่อนเราต้องคนที่ชอบรสชาติความความค่ะ
น้ากลิ่นของคะน้าก็จริงๆแล้วเนี่ยมันก็จะ
คล้ายๆกันกับเนื้อสัตว์เพราะว่าเนื้อ
สัตว์บางอันอย่างกุ้งเนี่ยบางคนก็ไม่ชอบ
ใส่ตั้งแต่แรกเขาจะใส่กุ้งตอนท้ายเพราะ
ว่ากุ้งเนี่ยมันเป็นเนื้อสัตว์ที่สุกง่าย
สัตว์เพราะว่าถ้าเขาใส่ตอนแรกเนี่ยกว่าจะ
ใส่เส้นใส่ไข่ใส่คะน้าเนี่ยกุ้งเนี่ย
โอ้โหแข็งละอยู่ใช่กูมาสุกนะอยู่กับความ
ร้อนนานๆมันจะแข็งแล้วเนื้อมันไม่หวานๆก็
อันนี้จริงๆแล้วอ่ะทุกอย่างพวกเนื้อสัตว์
หรือไข่หรือผักเหมือนมันก็แล้วแต่ความชอบ
ของคนว่าไอ้จังสุขแบบไหนขนาดเราก็แค่นั้น
ล่ะค่ะนักเรียนผัดให้เข้าจะกลับก็ตักใส่
จานนะคะเราก็รวยพริกไทยใช่พิษไทยต้องโรย
นะในประจัยใจเขาอร่อยนะเห็นแล้วก็หิวเลย
นะคะคุณนิคอาจจะทำวันนี้นะตอนเที่ยงฮ่าๆ
จริงๆแล้วแบบตั้งแต่มาอีกมาเบริการอยาก
กินผัดซีอิ้วมากๆแต่ยังไม่เจอร้านที่แบบ
ถูกใจอ่ะเหมือนไทยเนาะไทยสิ่งจริงๆการทํา
ผัดซีอิ๊วเนี่ยทำง่ายนะคะนักเรียนเพราะ
ว่ามันคุณนิคบอกหรือผู้หญิงบอกว่าเราอยาก
ใส่อะไรในขั้นตอนไหนก็ได้แต่ทำให้อร่อยก็
ค่อนข้างยากอยู่นะ
จริงๆแล้วเนี่ยที่คุณนิดยังไม่เคยทำผัด
ซีอิ้วนะเพราะว่าคุณเล็กอะเวลาขึ้นนี้แค่
เคยทำนะพวกผัดเส้นก๋วยเตี๋ยวเราเส้น
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวมันติดกะทะมากกว่าเข้าทายเกม
ติดกระทะขี้เกียจล้างก็เลยทำไม่จำเป็น
จริงๆนะจะไม่ค่อยอยากทำพวกผัดเส้นเส้น
อะไรแบบเนี้ย de ใช่เพราะว่าแบบผัดซีอิ๊ว
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยเคยกินที่ประเทศไทยเหมือนที่
ประเทศไทยเนี่ยไม่ใช่ถูกร้านทำอร่อยบาง
ร้านทำแล้วมันจะมีความแบบเหมือนใส่น้ำมัน
เยอะอ่ะเออกินแล้วมันรู้สึกแบบมันเรียน
เราบอกว่ามันเรียนบางครั้งเนี่ยบางร้านทำ
แล้วก็คิดว่าเอ๊ะอันนี้ผัดซีอิ๊วหรือ
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวคั่วไก่ก็สิ่งนี้มันไม่ดำหาให้
ใช่ใช่ค่ะเพราะมันจะมีอ่าเดี๋ยวเอารูปให้
นักเรียนดูนิดนึงนะคะว่ามันจะมี
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวคั่วไก่นั่นแหละที่มันจะคล้ายๆ
กันเฮ้ยใช่เส้นใหญ่เหมือนกัน
แต่ก๋วยเตี๋ยวคั่วไก่เนี่ย
การ์ตูน 4 แบบเนี้ยไม่ใส่ซีอิ้วดำๆ
เราก็อันนี้ไม่ใช่ผัดซีอิ้วไหมครับ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ใช่ไหมบอกแล้วอะไรที่ทำง่ายๆล่ะคะอาหาร
ไทยเนี่ยอร่อยยากนะทำให้อร่อยอ่ะค่อนข้าง
ยากยืมชายชัดนะเดี๋ยวต้องเตรียมไปหาดู
แล้วเอาไปทำแล้วชายหาดจะไปกินผัดซีอิ๊ว
แล้วค่ะนักเรียนคะตอนนี้คิวแล้วนะขอให้
ผู้หญิงกับคุณอีกในไปกินผัดซีอิ้วก่อนนะ
คะนักเรียนได้เจอไว้เจอกันใหม่รายคา
สวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ